الكثير من المسافرين يعتقدون ان هبوط
الطائره هو المرحله الاصعب في الرحله لكن
خبراء الطيران يؤكدون ان مرحله اقلاع
الطائره هي الاكثر خطوره بسبب احتمال
الاعطال والمشكلات المفاجئه ومن الحقائق
المهمه التي يجهلها المسافرين ان الاجواء
الماطره والرعديه تمر بالطائره بشكل مستمر
لكن الهندسه الدقيقه التي انشات عليها هذه
الطائرات تجعلها امنه ولا تسبب تلفها كذلك
فانت باقي طائرات الرحلات الطويله التي
تصل الى 18 ساعه في اليوم يمكن ان يرتاحوا
لعده ساعات خصوصا في الطائرات المجهزه
باماكن النوم لهم مثلا طائره بوينج 77
مجهزه بنحو 11 سريرا للطاقم وربما لا يعرف
الكثير من الناس ان الثقب الموجود في
نافذه الطائره له دور مهم جدا في الحفاظ
على الضغط الهوائي فيها حيث تساهم في
تنظيمه بشكل كبير وبالنسبه لاقنعه
الاكسجين الخاصه بالسلامه في الطائره التي
يتم الشرح عنها بدايه كل رحله فانها تحتوي
على 15 دقيقه فقط من الاكسجين لكن ليس
هناك داعي للرعب فهي كافيه في حال الازمات
التي يمكن ان تحدث لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات